- [Armando] Hi!
- [Officer] How are you?
- Good
Do you care for a concert?
- What was that?
- If you would like for us to do
a violin freestyle rap for you.
You're very welcome.
- That is so sick,
we'll park right up here,
and have you do it for us.
- I make sure it's safe
distance so we don't
risk infection-ing anyone.
Armando is an amazing violinist.
I am a freestyle rapper from the UK.
Whatever you want to hear a rap about,
I will then do that.
- [Officer] The Dodgers.
- [Chris] The Dodgers?
- [Officer] Yup
- [Chris] They're the...
- [Officer] Baseball
- Yup, good.
I'm not from here!
- [Officer] Positive police
community engagement.
Being positive.
- [Chris] Being positive,
police community engagement,
the dodgers, and one final one.
- Let's say the end of the virus.
- Armando, do you want to drop a beat?
Let's do this.
(violin music playing)
♪ The best strings, the best rhymes, ♪
♪ we've got on offer. ♪
♪ For these officers I'm
offering the Dodgers. ♪
♪ I'm seeing them in the stadium ♪
♪ I try some, knock it out the park, ♪
♪ when I'm running round the diamond. ♪
♪ First base, second base, third base, ♪
♪ fourth, oh, I've got the strength ♪
♪ I could kick like a horse, ♪
♪ I can pitch or catch it in the glove, ♪
♪ when push comes to shove. ♪
♪ When I'm rapping bout
baseball I don't know enough. ♪
♪ so I got to make the
more generic things. ♪
♪ I'm hoping the next month brings, ♪
♪ an end to this, get out of inside cause, ♪
♪ we're so bored of coronavirus. ♪
♪ We're hopin that the quarantine breaks ♪
♪ its curse and we can go outside ♪
♪ I never rehearse,
I always make it up ♪
♪ Yeah, an offer from this kid, ♪
♪ clever with the rhymes,
when I'm keepin' it positive. ♪
♪ I like this, nice look,
that's the flattery, ♪
♪ I'm positive like
the end of a battery. ♪
♪ You can see me yeah, ♪
♪ it's a clever kid ♪
♪ What's the opposite of positive, ♪
♪ that's negative. ♪
♪ We don't need that; with impunity ♪
♪ I drop bars and police the community. ♪
♪ Admittedly that's not what I do, ♪
♪ It's not the job of me, ♪
♪ it's the job of you, ♪
♪ and you two keep it positive ♪
♪ round this block. ♪
♪ Everybody's like 'it's our favorite cops' ♪
♪ Doffing caps if they wear one ♪
♪ They were amazed, I
like that one of you ♪
♪ is wearing the shades. ♪
♪ One of them a mirror, ♪
♪ one of them is matte. ♪
♪ One of them metallic blue, ♪
♪ and one of them is black. ♪
♪ But wearing them, you look real fly. ♪
♪ I can't wear shades
cause it hurts my eyes. ♪
(laughing)
- [Officer 2 ] Yeah!
(clapping)
I like it!
Way to go guys. You guys did great.
- [Office 1] Awesome job.
(thanks being passed around)
- [Office 2] Hey give me some right here.
I'll give you Corona and here's a lime.
(laughing)
(inaudible dialog)
- How scary is it rapping for
people with guns Armando?
- Can I not answer that?
- Very cool
- Very talented, great job guys.
- [Camera Man] God bless
All right, stay safe man.
All right, take care.
(upbeat music)
- It's scary cause we are both
in the country illegally.